there's a show called louie
with lucy canada if you watch that i'm
aware of it there's this moment
i think where an old guy is talking to
louis about
the best part about love is after you
break up
and it's remembering that like
remembering the good times and feeling
that loss the pain of that loss
the worst part about love is when you no
longer feel that pain
the pain of losing somebody
lasts longer is more intense and lasts
longer than the actual love
so his argument was like the pain is the
re is what love really is
wow in the same way that anger your
tombstone would arouse
is will last longer and that's
that's deeply like a human thing like
why do we
attach happiness to the way we should
remember others
it could be just anger i know so many
people who will have deeply complicated
feelings when
i i you know i did drugs for many years
so and i i spent time with some wild
people
and their parents were also wild people
and some of their parents have done
crazy things to them and
you know have created situations that
were
not uh productive for
child rearing yeah and so i know that
when those people die
it's going to be a very mixed bag like
there's going to be a lot of complex
emotions like hey
we loved that guy but also when we look
back uh he was a horrible father
a horrible husband but he was fun
and and and we don't put enough stock in
that but that will be a push and pull
yeah and i'll be the one kind of
bringing up like hey he was a lot of fun
yeah he was a lot remember when he he
stuck us
you know one of the things this
particular person i'm talking about
we were we were at a bar me and my
friend were there we're having dinner
and his father who was
you know an alcoholic and a you know a
guy that would go out every night and
didn't work
you know refused to work would lie and
say he was going to work
and then go to a bar i mean just a fun
person
and he he we were sitting at this
bar restaurant and the bartender we see
his father walk up to the bartender and
say
pointed us pointed our table and go and
put the thumbs up and the bartender
nodded
and then the father walked over to our
table and he said listen i just want to
let you know i just bought you dinner
and i looked at his son i said he's a
pretty good guy and then he
he climbed over the little fence down to
the water and got his little boat it was
a little cigarette boat and he just
drove away
and in about an hour later we uh we went
we said i think uh that guy took care of
the bill
but she said well go talk to the
bartender so we walked to the bartender
and he goes he handed us a bill and the
bill was for like a thousand dollars
and we said wait a minute what the hell
is going on and he goes the guy that
left an hour ago said you were going to
take care of his bill he's been drinking
here all week
and we go what are you talking about and
he goes remember he pointed at you he
put the thumbs up and you guys waved
yeah you remember that and then i go and
we went yeah and i just looked at my
friends
my friend and i went you know your dad
is just we're gonna remember him for all
kinds of reasons
but to you he was fun he was a lot of
fun he wasn't my dad
but i spent a lot of time with him i was
in two boating accidents with him
you know two boating accidents all
involved drugs yes he was
usually alcohol was involved when he
left his house um and when he was
at home as well but i was in two boating
accidents and do do you know how fun
someone has to be to get in a second
boating accident
do you know what a good time someone has
to be yeah
to get in a boat with them after you've
already gotten in
one wreck never get full to get what was
that line george bush never get fooled
again
right yeah so if you're getting fooled
again you know there's a reason for it
but he was
he was a fun guy he did have a death
wish the second boating accident he
grabbed me and said you can't hang out
with me anymore and i said why he goes
i'm trying to kill myself and i was like
oh and then i understood that like
oh the fun under the fun lived a very
destructive person
who not only was destructive but wanted
to die
you